bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'académie des coques numéro 2 l'épisode
vous avez pas mal plus y avait quelques
trucs qui n'allait pas on les a corrigés
aujourd'hui et avant tout disclaimer ne
fait pas ce qu'on va faire là en cours
parce que nous c'est pas un vrai course
à un faux courts je vous assure que
l'enquêté racines sont plus du tout au
lycée depuis bien des années quel âge on
y croit quel âge
pardon je sais pas si j'en ai deux
équipes vont s'affronter comme la
dernière fois
moi avec ma glace contre l'unc et
terrasses et des trois épreuves à la fin
de chaque épreuve professeur winston
attribuera une note
à chacune des deux équipes le professeur
a le droit de vous retirer des points si
vous faites les zigotos si vous faites
des coups que vous n'êtes pas censé
faire en cours il a aussi le droit de
vous mettre un blâme s'est fait une
faute grave
au bout de trois blâme vous allez au
coin et je vous jure que c'est pas un
avantage d'être sol dans la cabine des
grands capitaux de kung fu tout ça en
fait l'ena il a une tête à ce moment que
le sait conserver cette journée c'est
quoi il va s'en prendre nos propres
objectifs
aujourd'hui trois épreuves une épreuve
de physique-chimie la deuxième épreuve
les amis ce sera une épreuve d'arts
plastiques troisième épreuve les amis
comme l'un des enfants est une épreuve
deux ps ça fait du sport là bas oui les
amis êtes vous prêts à commencer ce
deuxième épisode de l'académie de caen
alors bas bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle classe je connais pas du tout
donc j'aimerais bien voir vos prénoms
sur un chevalet on se veut un le
tournage à part donc un petit chevalet
avec vos prénoms aucun des petites
feuilles à l'achat puis quand les
chevaliers oubliés ma trousse pour
prendre un crayon à lui
[Rires]
merci manquements passés en deux
couleurs pardon un blâme monsieur
lessard de blessure de la peine on n'a
pas commencé à paraître lundi
mais c'est lui ou devant le parquet
ouais je vais les garder secret
[Musique]
tout le monde attend
nous passons donc à la première épreuve
qui est une épreuve de physique-chimie
et pour commencer nous allons faire une
petite expérience va falloir gonfler un
ballon à l'aide de deux produits mais
c'est dangereux monsieur monsieur l'on
aime loris tu peut espérer vous avez
quand même fait un cheval est comme un
enfant de 7 ans et demi vous êtes
d'ailleurs vous êtes professeur le plat
donc ce que je vous propose avant toute
chose c'est d'équipé vos blouses qu'il
ya dans vos sacs haut et après on pourra
attaquer tout ça dans cette épreuve nous
allons devoir vous couvrir la blouse de
chaussures winston de sa couleur le plus
possible et à la fin un juge de
l'académie de versailles viendra nous
dire quelle couleur est le plus présente
sur la baisse de prix sur winston et ce
sera l'équipe qui gagnera le professeur
winston est d'accord avec ça nous avons
une petite bouteille dans cette
bouteille nous allons mettre du vinaigre
blanc a là ensuite on prend ce petit
ballon vous en avez tous devant vous
cette petite poudre blanche que vous
avez chacun dans vos petits flacons
devant vous qui va sur leur maître cesse
il a devancé pouvez vous calmer un peu
alors comment mettre la poudre là dedans
sans entonnoir va vous avez les feuilles
de m'échapper des mains tu tentes au
noir regardez vous mettez le ballon au
bout et ensuite on fait péter la poudre
et stands et j'essaie de faire tout
tomber ça allait super ce réellement je
voulais vous aider je pensais qu'ils ont
laissées dans l'expérience que vous
faites bien de l'âme d'un bloc l'ona bon
match est marqué au tableau on fait ça
et ensuite fait ceci le ballon
d'habitude il ya plus de poudre donc
c'est un peu plus impressionnant mais
mais vous allez pouvoir mettre plus de
gens et qui a du coup voilà donc la
liste des blâmes voilà non monsieur par
contre si la seppic avez vous avez dit
que c'était lui qui avait un blâme
ah bah oui donc vous allez avoir un
deuxième lame
attends on est en constituer une musique
très bon démaquillant de bla bla bla bla
à nous de jouer le premier qui réussit à
ça il a sa pipette mari l'acteur télé
kuteiba ouais j'ai rien et comme ça dans
ma scolarité inique il a fait des trucs
avant de faire semblant d'être non ça va
monsieur monsieur monsieur il a passé
quand justin a passé quand c'est par
mesure de sécurité
bazire fait à la base wade aussi un
petit blâme qui arrive là oui j'aime
bien c'est l'hôtel et on va les prendre
congé reste à l'ombre développement chez
northern ordre était donné
mais si on apprécie il n'y a pas besoin
de deux tubes alors le précipiter
directement dans le ballon ça c'est quoi
ça sert de vinaigre blanc dans la
bouteille
tu mets tout mettez tout mais mais elle
est encore plus grosse colère
elle est incroyable merci monsieur
monsieur monsieur mathias et me regarda
sa bosse en sommes par rapport en taille
de ballons mal acquis alors qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous avez ajouté à
votre expérience puisque permis un petit
peu de teinture la base sur la fin les
gars vous abusez de ouf vous abusez des
oufs égard non mais cette expérience a
très bien fonctionné non en bloc alors
mettre en breton et movie en tout cas ma
vie oui ça on l'a oublié tout à l'heure
on sait pas où le mettre
et donc c'est quoi la suite de
l'expérience du coup oui oui par contre
monsieur au niveau des ballons pourquoi
sommes ici c'est plus rempli que
d'autres parce qu'ils avaient plus en
quantité de 24 x files voulait attraper
le pêcheur si je puis me permettre
il ya clairement réclame du côté de
troisième l'a donc un blâme au coin si
vous êtes déjà trembler monsieur oui bon
d'accord je prends simple à ce monsieur
de ce qu'ils allaient feuilles
excusez moi monsieur je me permets de
dire oui par rapport au tableau
est-ce que ça attendait ça oui ces deux
solutions aqueuses donc peut être
monsieur salle attention à vous oui vite
vous allez au coin bagla par contre
cobos cette bouteille tu veux risquerait
d'avoir un accident par qu'on vous aide
au coin vous êtes au corps oui c'est pas
beaucoup alors passé en coin ouais ouais
vous parliez de l'eau l'eau dans 20 30
ans et nous ça va dans les mails en
droit canon un plan qui est derrière
vous par exemple a besoin d'autres oui
bah ça sert à quelque chose de plantes
menacées un ficus c'est une plante
d'intérieur ou d'accord les faits c'est
qu'on sait que je viens vous voir en
train de me jeter du produit sur moi
tous les deux vous avez un peuple chacun
monsieur bah vraiment au moment grâce à
vous savez quoi vous sortez de cour vous
allez voir le proviseur vous allez dans
son bureau du délégué je peux
l'accompagner au oui bien sûr alors nous
allons parler du tableau périodique
je connais par coeur le tableau
périodique là c'est fait je peux
m'asseoir du coup j'ai raccompagné si
vous restez sage qu'elle est qu'elle est
là l'élément un périodique numéro quatre
du tableau des éléments le nucleus vous
avez quand même bien tout ça dans un
beau un bel état là monsieur vous l'avez
vu c'était un ingénieux vous l'avez vu
et du coup il n'y a pas de blâme ah
ouais c'est sûr c'est bon c'est peu qui
m'assurent mots ok vous pouvez revenir
si ses réserves si je n'ose il a ouvert
son bloc notes il a marqué ses bonbons
non non non
je rejoins signé damien système cave
ouais ok c'est vrai mes amis c'est la
fin de cette épreuve de physique-chimie
le dos a été pas mal touché durant cette
épreuve
il est maintenant temps de voir quelle
couleur est la plus présente sur la
blouse du professeur wilson pour savoir
quelle équipe à gagner sur room c'est
clairement le rose bonbon et évidemment
c'est dur aussi alors baghlan excusez
moi quels sont les regarder les couleurs
rose et bleu violet on a l'impression
qu'il ya plus de bleu alors qu'en fait
du rose là où il ya du violet c'est du
rose du coup je n'ai rien à gré mal gré
je suis désolé de te dire
et dès qu'il ya du violet saisir cas du
rose où il a tellement fait pas beaucoup
plus de bleu mais non si déjà on regarde
tous cette surface la ouate en mai
terrain avant leur baratin tu viens de
mettre du bleu une fiche
tu sais quoi une fiche à paris et les
gens peuvent vous grosse bleus n'en
doutent choisir musique d'ascenseur la
fiche apparaît maintenant et vous pouvez
voter
[Musique]
du coup comme on n'a pas la réponse
parce que c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué à juger on va dire un point
partout vous êtes d'accord avec ça ouais
ok deuxième époque allez on y retourne
tous n'aura soir les amis il est temps
de passer la deuxième épreuve
l'un plastique vous avez devant vous non
pas une drogue illicite mais un bloc
large et vous allez devoir faire le
visage d'une personne de l'équipe
adverse oreilles mais bush dieu cheveux
c'est chaud mais tu peux donner une
forme de cheveux avaient déjà fini ouais
ok mon travail ici notre émotion c'est
toi ok voilà pas mal bien évidemment on
va on va mettre deux heures à faire donc
il ya un temps limite qui est fixé à 20
minutes tout est clair vous avez devant
vous une multitude d'instruments je ne
comprends rien très énigmatique mais ça
peut être utile top chrono
vous lancez le chrono professeur layton
et le court no comment maintenant très
bien ça les parties non mais ça glisse
tout seul comme dans du beurre
je retiens c'est monsieur n'est pas
conseillée par regarder ci peut rien
c'est dégueulasse mais fait mais c'est
hyper dur
oh la belle tête à des batailles sont en
train de faire un terrain garde et
gérard des buteurs à 6 g 1 débutait
assez
qu'est ce que tu penses de tomber le
mais que c'était je m'occupe du truc
principal ok mais c'est hyper messieurs
demande de temps la poterie le nez ok
par contre si vous faites un énorme pic
akitani contre tout amalgame et gallo
vient de le dire tout le reste est juste
pour ma blague ça veut rien dire
je crois que dans un but plus j'ai
récupéré mes trucs hyper violent si vous
faites c'est monsieur manque une oreille
en fête commence à 8 mois qu'ils
n'auraient pas ça vous aurez juste toi
ma glace se lève j'ai pu d'oreilles fois
vos deux oreilles vont très bien voilà
irak au dramont n'importe quoi c'est des
conneries vas-y chez notre façon ces
dégâts
fait faux faux une belle calvitie en
fait tu vois j'ai une très belle
calvitie par le magnat ouais ouais ouais
c'est j'essaie de faire une texture le
savent peut-être pas assez dommage il
l'a vu sur le deuxième but il s'appelle
m'a regardé comme ça glisse il vous
reste dix minutes ça le temps passe si
vite
on peut avoir des points en plus si on
finit en avant pas du tout prend on va
utiliser ton petit filet mille fois
mieux monsieur j'ai refait un regarder
mon t-shirt
donc si on vous arrache et oui mais
c'est pas très malin mathématiquement
nous là vous y arrivez chez google nous
caler papier par an 4 ok ok j accepte la
qualif en soyez prudents parce que vous
prenez pas de l'argile
on remet ça n'arrête pas le bon résultat
pour ce désagrément
on a trop d'eau dans la pièce midi file
de la po et le bas attendons la noyade
ou blanc il ya maintenant on joue alors
la voie là haut
quand nous avons deux personnes qui vont
comme en rêve fou lancé moyenne quelque
chose et tous les os mais bon
aucoin et pourquoi j'ai besoin de
monsieur pasqua mon nez mais le nez j'ai
pas touché juste relever leur ai dit tu
l'a vraiment fait comme ça contre le mec
avait oublié qu'il était mauvais ouahmed
l'annoncé vous l'avez vu là monsieur ces
compteurs moi je reste pas dans cette
pièce si ça continue comme ça si apam
aussi un pas plus loin
il vous reste 5 minutes pile poil donc
attention ça va
pas vu pas pris et mec regarde vous
sortez vous avez vous pour retourner
non mais vous allez au cp vous sortez
oui vous sortez de suite vous allez chez
le cpe monsieur j'ai fini choix
ouais c'est très c'est vrai elle m'a dit
que c'était bon là ça peut aller malades
si vous êtes sages vous pouvez rester
ici et de votre colère assure bien faire
les choses aussi mais surtout cave
merci merci vous devez vous poser ici
mais vous savez ça t'en penses quoi
[Musique]
c'est fini c'est ce mec ça ça c'est de
l'art cela se vendent sur yvette très
cher attend de voir mc la semaad marché
noir semag leur nom à vous de deviner
écoutez je vais commencer par ici je
vous aide c'est au rize le mois ce qui
s'était rassis des du moins notre vision
de tes racines donc c'est comme ça que
jours
premier point fort on pète amovible
design et par magna en personne les
oreilles décollées pour bien entendre
les avis des abonnés ce n'est pas fini
les petites oreilles aurait décollé
naizot fait pas décoller parce qu'il n'a
pas les oreilles décollées regardera des
couleurs il n'a pas les horaires à m
quand vous le désirez exactement avait
regardé la up
c'est la vie la vraie vie bhl on peut
faire ce qu'on veut alors voici poucave
koukal cook a alors attendu la même
expression faciale que monsieur picard
parce qu' une vidéo d'accord regardez
bien la ressemblance avec son nez
proéminent et la veine fémorale
alors on a un problème avec la
proportion des oreilles nous on s'est
dit que c'était quelqu'un qui était allé
coûte donc c'était peut-être
métaphoriquement plus gros et c'est pas
du tout ce que vous avez pas réussi à
faire serait plus petit par exemple non
non aux faiseurs winston c'est à vous de
départager ces deux véritables oeuvres
d'art
alors c'est un peu compliqué parce que
les deux ont un style différent ainsi le
propre j'ai rarement vu d'aussi belles
pièces merci merci professeur j'ai buzzé
d'avouer que ces magnats qui a quasiment
tout fait pour un medic mais j'ai une
préférence pour une des deux oeuvres
c'est le 2 damien et thomas paf
merci professeur très bon choix parce
que la petite veine salon
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous passons
maintenant à la troisième épreuve qui
est comme la dernière fois de
l'acrosport veuillez accueillir damien
et thomas sieber et maintenant magna
époux cave et donc comme la dernière
fois chaque équipe va faire trois
figures différentes chaque figure vos
certains points donc les figures bleus
balle au pied s'il te plaît deux mois
les amis que nous avons de très belles
figures d'acrosport classés par couleur
les bleus 24 les vertes vallées 6 les
oranje mal 8 les rouges valdys vous
devez en faire trois une figure est
validée quand vous avez tenu la position
exacte pendant trois secondes la
dernière fois j'ai failli crever
littéralement pendant le tournage cette
fois on a mis un petit matelas l'a donc
quand vous sentez que la figure l'un de
vous deux aura tendance à tomber fait
ensemble récemment très bel exemple
marche je vois qu'on a trois personnes
qui n'ont pas leurs tenues de sport nous
et qu'il y avait donc il ya d'office - 1
- savais pas si c'était pour changer - 1
voilà pour rappel c'est ce qui vous a
fait perdre la dernière fois we make
c'est ce qui nous a fait perdre à dr
fois ok les gars m'ont traîné des
figures vous allez faire à la caméra
nous allons commencer par une figure
assez simple que je vais intitulé la
figure on sait pas trop ce savons pas où
va s'en va c'est l'un l'autre étant une
jambe de chacun assez simple une verte
quand même seibert hélas ah ah oui alors
là provient où je viens pour n'autoriser
que c'était peut-être qu'on va mourir
il aura sa tête entre mes cuisses et le
tête à queue y restent invaincus une
deuxième où c'est le drapeau pencher
elle aimait faisait bing on l'a déjà
fait plein de fois allez les gars on
commence par la mer on se pose on vous
regarde on se contente n'oubliez pas
faut tenir trois secondes combats
simples plutôt comme ça se ferait 3 2 1
tara compris même si je passe ma jambe
allait il ya qu à sa jambe gauche
3 enfin connais mon mariage pourrait
bien vous coller à deux trois six et
validé profession oui c'est quatre
points romantique en plus
alors attention à la mise en place qui
est sûr pour celle ci qu'est ce qu'on
est con ce prêt franchement valu des
fois je sais qu'on dirait pas mais je
vous jure il ya un truc comme ça toi
j'étais amoureux dans sa partie droite
les mecs étaient présents vous êtes
vraiment un jeu 1 2 3 le vms et une
orange et vert de calais une orange dans
un calme là par contre ça qui allait
bien quoi je crois quoi je crois que
j'en étais moins de bonnes choses comme
ça va à peu près il faut que j'arrive à
compacter à dos les valides et les aime
et les mecs vous êtes hyper vous avez
pensé jamaa dans une carrière dans la
course warbasse une passion faite hier
il ya une ligue1 d'acrosport ya des
grosses sommes vus il ya ce ça nous fait
donc six +8 +8
22 points est-ce que c'est pas le
rapport à quelqu'un 22 points record
jamais dans le monde voilà je veux qu'on
fasse bien qu'il faut 22 21 ça
les gars ça on doit strates et après
vaudois s'est raté tellement vous avez
gêné tient les oranje bon mais il
dévoile la stratégie mais y dévoilent
leur l'attraper deux figures facile et
ensuite on vous dévoile deux granges
donc de bleu ça nous rapporte 6 points
chacune
et ensuite la route ne rapportera 10
points donc on sera à 22 comme vous sauf
que nous on a un malus de -1 et vous -
de donc si on réussit ce nom figure on a
gagné cette épreuve première figure
assez simple celle-ci bleus et s'en vont
le simple elle a juste atteint mes
jambes ça va deuxième figure celle ci
c'est la même sauf qu'elle tend les
jambes et je m'appuie sur ses jambes un
beau carrière et là surprise pour
narguer surprise parce que sinon vous
n'allez pas être concentré pendant 7
dollars on est pareils préparer allez
vas-y tu te mets comme ça comme ça je me
mets peut-être plus de sens là ouais ok
mais ouais ok ok au cas où donc c'est
toi qui te supporter ouais ok ok l'asie
français de la france suit là à 2,3
allez hop c'est géré 7,6 à l'infini ses
promesses à la figure on vous a fait
chier quand il a fait la tour du pin up
bel endroit où vous allez allez jamais
je suis là à droite tout acheter mon
arrière et fait ouais vas-y offert
calibrage hockey inquiète
vas-y hockey oh put on pouvait le faire
vas-y envoie une jambe vas-y je te tiens
en voilà deux jambes ok on est en quarts
est parfait regardez pas tant excuse moi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est le mec il mesure l'homme
le tfc nombreux mégots sur 1 170 degrés
on voulait se refaire si vous voulez
dire l'enfer ne regarde pas son degré
zéro race noire y arriver vas-y vas-y
balance valence valence hockey aux trois
secondes seulement
à l'aller on l'analyse et attendent de
voir avec les rouges c'est une figure
qui s'appelle la boulette je dois porter
la boulette
la boulette de talent je veux qu'on joue
à tous les autres c'est que des trucs ou
si vous le faites ce sera du toit on
peut le respect énorme bon on y va dit
c'est quoi le plus simple c'est que tu
mettes tes jambes là et qu'ensuite pas
que tu relèves tes jambes je pense
ouais tu vois le dos fait avorter direct
on sera dos au label à l'état mais est
ce qu'on a vraiment trois secondes
c'était sur dabo secondes mais c'est un
bel 3e allez vas-y vas-y tu à choper le
truc là ça va pas marcher
je suis prêt il a plus de force et c'est
d'appuyer très fort avant même de faire
ton équilibre voilà accepté attendez
attendez ce qu'on n'aurait pas fait un
alors ça n'aurait pas fait un 6/6 et on
n'avait pas fait un s'est passé 1
combien s'invite s'est dit sensible
alors 22 ex-aequo
sauf que un point en moins pas personne
parce que vous avez tous les doubles is
it vous à faire de son enquête au match
ce qui vous donne 20 points en moins
pour nous parce que j'ai oublié mes
affaires de sport ce qui nous donne 21
c'est dégueulasse et est prêt on a gagné
l'épreuve un copain juste à cause d'une
de des sports les gars
sélectionnez to be table ou moins de bon
résultat final bon on va faire laurent
alors première épreuve ex-aequo à la
blood du professeur était aussi bloquée
ross
la deuxième épreuve il est évident que
vous avez gagné la patrie je peux
l'admettre maintenant j'ai encaissé ces
bons termes et maintenant voilà avec le
recul on peut admettre qu'ils ont en
même temps j'ai j'ai zéro et des magnats
elle était sous l'eau c'est ok on a
fauté et ruiné le truc troisième épreuve
l'acrosport je dois être honnête c'était
incroyable cette tour de piste
improvisée
il ya même des touristes convient d'en
devenir et faire à côté c'était tout
mais on a tout donné pour réussir cette
filière rouge est réservé une
fois de plus notre problème
et c'était le cas dans notre scolarité
c'est l'assiduité être à l'écouté des
professeurs et faire ce qu'il nous dise
comme par exemple ramener nos affaires
de sport tas vous a coûté un point sûr
de ramener vos affaires de sport ramenez
vos affaires de sport et votre scolarité
sera incroyable on vous l'assuré
c'est le message est également à cause
de ces affaires de sport donc il ya
égalité maintenant qu'est ce que les
gens pensent une fiche s'affiche
maintenant pour voter qui a le mieux
réussi ses délires d'acrosport bon qu'il
ou ma glace cuisine on va voir et on
verra les résultats de tous les votes et
on verra d'après les gens qui a gagné la
vidéo du coup et puis c'est la fin
c'était incroyable c'est même si
j'aimerais qu'on relance l'acrosport en
france voilà que ça de même un peu que
les gens fassent des vidéos merci les
mecs je fais un petit câlin général
enfin qu'un général dans cette vidéo on
put là seraient bientôt
[Musique]